This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When Saru Najarian was about 10, his pastime was collecting baseball and basketball cards. These were hard to come by in Cyprus, where he grew up. So when Saru's cousin pestered him to share his cards with her, he always said no. But she didn't give up. As she pestered and begged and pleaded, It came to a boiling point where I got so angry that everything blacked out and I slapped her really hard.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。萨鲁·纳贾里安大约10岁时，最大的消遣是收集棒球和篮球卡。在他成长的塞浦路斯，这些卡片很难弄到。所以每当萨鲁的表妹死缠烂打地要他分享卡片时，他总是拒绝。但她没有放弃。随着她不断纠缠、哀求和恳求，事情终于到了爆发点，我愤怒到极点，以至于眼前一片漆黑，狠狠地扇了她一巴掌。
Saru's arm seemed to act of its own volition. A second later, I came back into the reality and I saw her crying and had no idea what I had done. Paula Reed experienced something similar at the same age. She was a budding environmentalist with a peace ecology flag hanging on her bedroom wall. One afternoon, she heard the cracking of trees and a low rumble. She realized that her neighbor was knocking down trees to
萨鲁的手臂似乎不受控制地自己行动起来。一秒钟后，我回到现实中，看到她在哭泣，完全不知道自己做了什么。保拉·里德在同样的年纪也经历过类似的事情。她是一个刚崭露头角的环保主义者，卧室墙上挂着一面和平生态旗。一天下午，她听到树木断裂的声音和低沉的轰鸣声。她意识到邻居正在砍树，以便
build himself a shorter driveway. He was using a bulldozer. This neighbor came up the road in the bulldozer and was pushing over trees and something in my head just snapped. My head just snapped. Paula's dad had bought a machete in his travels. Without thinking, Paula seized the weapon. Its blade was about as long as her arm. In shorts and bare feet, she climbed up on the bulldozer and swung the blade. Metal struck metal.
为自己建一条更短的车道。他开着一台推土机。这个邻居开着推土机沿着路上来，推倒了树木，我脑子里的某根弦突然断了。我的脑子突然断了。保拉的父亲在旅行中买过一把大砍刀。想都没想，保拉就抓起了这把武器。它的刀片大约和她的手臂一样长。她穿着短裤，赤着脚，爬上推土机，挥舞着刀片。金属撞击着金属。
As the bulldozer stopped and retreated, Paula chased after it, cutting ribbons in the air with a machete. I have no idea where that came from, but I was in a complete wild red rage. I was in a complete wild red rage. This week on the show, Wild Red Rage. We continue our Emotions 2.0 series with a favorite episode about the moments
当推土机停下来并后退时，保拉追了上去，挥舞着大砍刀在空中划出带状的轨迹。我不知道那是什么，但我当时处于一种完全狂野的血红怒火中。我当时处于一种完全狂野的血红怒火中。本周的节目是：狂野的血红怒火。我们继续“情绪2.0”系列节目，为您带来一期备受喜爱的节目，探讨那些
when we suddenly snap. Such rage can harm others, it can harm us. But it turns out we would be worse off without it. The deep logic of irrational rage, this week on Hidden Brain. This is the story of a woman who snapped. I would say that I'm a gentle person, and that's me putting it optimistically. Jess Cavender always thought of herself as a timid person. Timid to the point of push over. My brother wasn't shy about telling me that I was a doormat for most of my life, and I didn't want to see myself as a doormat, but I also didn't have evidence to the contrary. In elementary school, for example, Jess saved up years of pocket money and
我们突然情绪失控（情绪崩溃）的时刻。这种愤怒会伤害他人，也会伤害我们。但事实证明，如果没有它，我们的处境会更糟。不理智愤怒背后的深层逻辑，本周《隐藏的大脑》。这是一个关于一个情绪失控的女人的故事。我会说我是一个温柔的人，这还是我往乐观了说。杰丝·卡文德一直认为自己是一个胆小的人。胆小到任人欺负的地步。我的兄弟毫不避讳地告诉我，我这一生大部分时间都是个逆来顺受的出气筒，我不想把自己看作是一个出气筒，但我也没有相反的证据。例如，在小学时，杰丝攒了多年的零花钱和
birthday cash, storing her savings in a music box. Her dream? A much coveted trampoline. Finally, one day, she had enough money. She and her dad drove to Sam's Club. I bought this trampoline and I was so excited. Until her trampoline was taken over by intruders. My two siblings, my older brother and younger sister, would bounce on the trampoline as well and sometimes I couldn't get it to myself the way I'd like it. Jess's siblings
生日现金，把积蓄存放在一个音乐盒里。她的梦想？一个让人垂涎的三层蹦床。终于有一天，她有足够的钱了。她和爸爸开车去了山姆会员店。我买了这个蹦床，我太兴奋了。直到她的蹦床被不速之客霸占。我的两个兄弟姐妹，我的哥哥和弟弟，也会在蹦床上蹦蹦跳跳，有时我无法像自己希望的那样独自使用它。杰丝的兄弟姐妹
didn't just hog the trampoline. They treated her as if she were an unwelcome guest. Jess tried to get her dad to step in. Instead of helping, he offered her some advice. My dad suggested to me that I, you know, charge them to use the trampoline, since it was my trampoline and I had done all the work to save for it, that I should charge them a fee to use it. He might as well have suggested she punch someone in the face.
不仅仅是独占蹦床。他们把她当成不受欢迎的访客对待。杰丝试图让父亲介入。他没有帮忙，反而给她出谋划策。我爸爸建议我，你知道的，向他们收取使用蹦床的费用，既然这是我的蹦床，而且我付出了所有的努力才攒够钱买下它，我应该向他们收取使用费。他完全可以说建议她一拳打在别人的脸上。
Her siblings didn't even bother arguing with her. They just ignored her. I don't know how I would have ever enforced charging 25 cents for my siblings to use it. They certainly would just be like no walk past me and get on the trampoline. Jess did not experience the slights with fury. She accepted them with resignation. Over the years, there were other moments like this, moments that would have sparked anger in some people.
她的兄弟姐妹甚至懒得和她争论。他们直接忽视了她。我不知道我该如何强制执行向我的兄弟姐妹收取25美分的使用费。他们肯定会说“不”，然后从我身边走过，直接上蹦床。杰丝并没有带着愤怒经历这些轻视。她逆来顺受地接受了这一切。多年来，还有其他这样的时刻，这些时刻会在某些人心中激起愤怒。
But Jess usually kept her cool, until one night, years later, when she didn't. She was in graduate school, living with two roommates in off-campus housing. It has all of the trimmings of being sort of college living where you're paying for a lot and not getting very much and people are packed in. Late one night, Jess was jolted awake by a sound. I hear heavy footfalls going down the stairs. Jess immediately thought she knew what had happened. Her roommate Kim had torn her Achilles tendon and was wearing a boot. Jess figured that Kim had fallen on the stairs.
但杰丝通常能保持冷静，直到多年后的一个夜晚，她再也无法保持冷静。当时她在读研究生，和两个室友住在校外宿舍里。那里有着大学生活的种种特色，你要花很多钱却得不到多少东西，人们挤在一起。深夜，杰丝被一个声音惊醒。我听到沉重的脚步声下楼。杰丝立刻觉得自己知道发生了什么。她的室友金撕裂了跟腱，正戴着护具。杰丝以为金在楼梯上摔倒了。
She leaped out of bed, threw on her robe, and opened her bedroom door. Her other roommate, Shelby, opened her door at the same time. She'd also heard the noise. She's looking at me and I'm looking at her and Kim's not at the bottom of the stairs, so we both just run down the stairs to see what had happened. Well the both of us arrive at the bottom of the stairs and a very large man with my kitchen rag held over his face comes wheeling out of the kitchen with a gun pointed at us. The first thing Jess took in about the man was his size. He was at least six foot five.
她从床上跳起来，套上长袍，打开了卧室门。她的另一个室友谢尔比同时打开了门。她也听到了声音。她看着我，我看着谢尔比，而金并不在楼梯底部，所以我们两个就顺着楼梯跑下去看发生了什么。当我们两个到达楼梯底部时，一个身材魁梧的男人用我的厨房抹布蒙着脸，从厨房里冲出来，手里拿着一把枪指着我们。杰丝对这个男人的第一印象是他的体型。他至少有六英尺五英寸高。
He was about a head taller than she was. All I could see was his eyes. The sclera of his eyes were yellow. And aside from that, really I was staring at the barrel of the gun. The man yelled, where's the money? Get the money. Go upstairs. Standing there in her robe, with a gun pointed at her head, Jess did not snap.
他比她高出一个头。我只能看到他的眼睛。他的眼白是黄色的。除此之外，实际上我一直盯着枪管。那个男人大喊：钱呢？拿钱来。上楼去。穿着长袍站在那里，枪口指着头部，杰丝并没有情绪失控。
Instead, her mind became cool and analytical. What could she do to get out of the situation? Out of the corner of her eye, she noticed a movement. Another man had emerged from a side room. another man had emerged from a side room. I know that they want something valuable. And I have nothing. I'm aware that I have no cash. I have no TV screens. The man with a gun motioned for the two women to go up the stairs,
相反，她的头脑变得冷静而有分析力。她能做些什么来摆脱这种处境？眼角余光中，她注意到一个动作。另一个男人从侧室里钻了出来。另一个男人从侧室里钻了出来。我知道他们想要有价值的东西。而我什么都没有。我知道我没有现金。我没有电视屏幕。拿枪的男人示意两个女人上楼，
presumably to fetch their wallets. Shelby, normally a ball of energy, had gone still. I discovered that she's frozen. She isn't blinking, she's not looking at me, she's not moving. So I put my hand on her back and I say, everything's going to be okay. We're going upstairs, just give them what they want. As Jess and Shelby climbed the stairs, the robbers came up behind them. One of the guys puts his hand on my butt to like push me and that's when it occurred to me that something sexually violent might happen.
大概是去拿她们的钱包。谢尔比平时是个精力充沛的人，此时却一动不动。我发现她僵住了。她不眨眼，不看着我，也不动。所以我把手放在她的背上说，一切都会好起来的。我们上楼去，把他们想要的东西给他们就行了。当杰丝和谢尔比爬楼梯时，劫匪跟在她们后面。其中一个人把手放在我的屁股上，像是推我一样，就在那时我意识到可能会发生某种性暴力事件。
Still, Jess felt no rage. The second robber took Shelby into her room. The first man, the one with the gun, followed Jess into her bedroom. And he's yelling, get on the bed. And that's when the sort of thought, there's no way in hell that I will get on this bed, not for anything. It's a second story building. I probably would have jumped out of the window before I actually got on the bed.
尽管如此，杰丝并没有感到愤怒。第二个劫匪把谢尔比带进了她的房间。第一个拿枪的男人跟着杰丝进了她的卧室。他大喊：躺到床上。就在那时，脑子里闪过这样一个念头：我绝不可能躺到这张床上，无论如何都不行。这是一栋二层楼的建筑。在真正躺到床上之前，我可能就已经跳窗逃跑了。
JS Just kept thinking, what could she give the man to make him leave? AMT I'm looking around my room and I'm looking for something of value. I have stacks of books, I have dance clothes, I have all sorts of things that could not possibly, in my mind, register giving to him. I'm just looking around for something valuable to give to him so that he will leave. And I look down and I see my camera. The camera she used for work. Now my camera is the main way that I provide for myself, and that's how I was making enough money to really to feed myself.
杰丝一直在想，她能给这个男人什么东西让他离开？我环顾四周，寻找有价值的东西。我有一堆书，我有舞蹈服装，我有各种各样在我看来不可能送给他的东西。我只是环顾四周，想找点有价值的东西给他，好让他离开。然后我低头看到了我的相机。她工作用的相机。现在，我的相机是我养活自己的主要方式，也是我赚取足够资金来真正养活自己的方式。
And so that represented to me my livelihood, my survival. I had a split-second emotional response to it, thinking, no, he doesn't get that. And that's when everything changed. Jess did not snap when two men invaded her home. She didn't snap when one of them touched her. She didn't snap when she was forced at gunpoint into her bedroom and told to get on the bed. But when she realized the robber might take her camera...
所以这对我来说代表着我的生计，我的生存。我对它产生了电光石火般的情感反应，心想：不，他不能拿走这个。就在那时，一切都变了。当两个男人闯入她的家中时，杰丝并没有情绪失控。当其中一个人触碰她时，她没有情绪失控。当她被枪逼着走进卧室并被告知躺到床上时，她没有情绪失控。但当她意识到劫匪可能会拿走她的相机时……
That's when I realized this person has no right to come in here and to demand my things or to even be in my space. That was really the first time that I had a strong response to this person violating me. I looked at the gun, just squarely faced him in a way that I don't think I've ever done to anyone and said, get out. Get out of my house. You do not belong here. Jess could hear the man's accomplice in the other room shouting, shoot her, shoot her. Jess spotted her cell phone. She grabbed it. The robber saw what she was doing.
就在那时我意识到，这个人没有权利闯入这里，要求得到我的东西，甚至没有权利进入我的空间。这真的是我第一次对这个人侵犯我做出强烈的反应。我看着那枪，直面着他，用一种我想我从未对任何人有过的态度说：滚开。滚出我的房子。你不属于这里。杰丝听到那个男人的同伙在另一个房间里大喊：开枪打死她，开枪打死她。杰丝发现了她的手机。她抓起了手机。劫匪看到了她的举动。
And as I got my hand on it, he jumped on top of me and we're rolling on the floor fighting each other. He's using one hand to try and pry the cell phone out, and I'm using the same hand that's on the cell phone to dig my fingernails into his skin, and then the other hand to try and pry the gun out of his hand. Something primal stirred inside Jess. She was suddenly consumed by blinding rage. His chest is on my back, his arms are around my arms. He's completely sort of crouched over and around me as we're falling on our sides and
当我把手搭在手机上时，他扑到了我身上，我们在地板上打滚，互相搏斗。他用一只手试图把手机撬出来，我用放在手机上的同一只手把指甲深深地抠进他的皮肤里，然后用另一只手试图把枪从他手里撬出来。某种原始的本能杰丝内心被唤醒了。她突然被盲目的愤怒所吞噬。他的胸膛压在我的背上，他的手臂环抱着我的手臂。当我们侧身摔倒时，他完全蹲伏在我身上和周围，
I'm kicking and scratching and... The ones are flooding her mind, not survival. Don't let him win. Somehow that mattered. I was using every ounce of my physical strength and not caring that I was inflicting pain. And actually being like, that's fine, that's the point, if to get this phone back out of his hand. I don't know why I was more focused on the phone
而我在踢打、抓挠……理智充斥着她的脑海，而不是生存。别让他赢。不知何故，这很重要。我使出了浑身的力气，根本不在乎自己正在给对方造成痛苦。实际上我觉得：很好，这正是目的，只要把这手机从他手里夺回来就行。我不知道为什么我更专注于手机
than the gun, but I was. The second robber barged into the bedroom. There were now two of them in the room, but she had no thought for risk or danger. Something new had taken over. I just started screaming. A full-on high-pitched, blood-curling screech of a scream. And apparently my scream was so loud that I woke up one neighbor who was wearing headphones and then the other neighbor who was asleep on the other side.
而不是枪，但我就是这样。第二个劫匪冲进了卧室。现在房间里有两个人了，但她完全没有考虑风险或危险。某种新的东西占据了上风。我开始尖叫。发出一种全力以赴的、高亢的、令人毛骨悚然的尖叫声。显然我的尖叫声太大了，以至于吵醒了一个戴着耳机睡觉的邻居，然后又吵醒了睡在另一侧的另一个邻居。
The men were so startled by the screams that they took off. One grabbed Jess' laptop on his way out. Jess' scream woke up her other roommate. Unbelievably, Kim had slept through the whole thing. And she opened the door and says, you know, what's wrong? I was like, call the police. In that moment, Jess Cavender, who had lived her life as a timid person, had no sense that she had acted out of character.
这几个人被尖叫声吓得落荒而逃。一个人在离开时顺手拿走了杰丝的笔记本电脑。杰丝的尖叫声吵醒了她的另一个室友。难以置信的是，金竟然睡过了整场风暴。她打开门说，你知道的，怎么了？我说，快报警。那一刻，一直作为胆小鬼生活的杰丝，并没有觉得自己表现得与平时判若两人。
All that unfolded was in no way, shape or form unnatural or surprising to me in the moment. It was what needed to happen. I wasn't surprised at myself until but later when I was like, I cannot for the life of me believe that I looked at a guy who's holding a gun at my head and decided that I was going to yell at him. Or fight. Yeah. Or fight. Yeah, or fight.
当时发生的一切对我来说绝不是不自然或令人惊讶的。那是当时必须做的事情。我直到后来才对自己感到惊讶，当时我想：打死我也无法相信，我会看着一个拿枪指着我头的男人，决定对大喊大叫。或者反抗。是的。或者反抗。是的，或者反抗。
Jess's story reveals a strange truth about our capacity for fury. It often arrives without warning. It seems to have a mind of its own. We can ignore serious provocations for years, and then, boom, we snap. Only later do we look back at our actions in wonder. When we come back, understanding the triggers that can push even the most mild-mannered among us to see red. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. A defining quality of wild red rage is that it often comes out of nowhere.
杰丝的故事揭示了关于我们愤怒能力的一个奇怪真相。它往往在没有警告的情况下到来。它似乎有自己的思想。我们可以连续多年忽视严重的挑衅，然后，轰的一声，我们就情绪失控了。直到事后，我们才会惊叹地回看自己的行为。广告回来后，我们将了解那些能将我们当中脾气最温和的人也逼得怒不可遏的导火索。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。狂野血红怒火的一个决定性特质是，它往往毫无征兆地出现。
It takes over our minds and deprives us of reason and logic. When Jess Cavender lost it and literally fought a robber who had a gun pointed at her head, she took a very serious risk. She and her roommates could have ended up dead. In retrospect, you could say it was foolhardy and irrational. All this presents a mystery. It's taken millions of years of evolution to produce the human brain. It has an exquisite capacity for reason and logic. Why would natural selection install
它接管了我们的思想，剥夺了我们的理智和逻辑。当杰丝·卡文德情绪失控，并真的和一个用枪指着她头部的劫匪搏斗时，她冒了极大的风险。她和她的室友们可能会丧命。事后看来，你可以说这是鲁莽和不理智的。这一切呈现出一个谜。人类大脑经历了数百万年的进化才得以产生。它具有无与伦比的理智和逻辑能力。为什么自然选择要设置
a circuit breaker to undermine our capacity for logical thinking? Doug Fields has long puzzled over this question. His interest in rage grows out of his fascination with the brain, but it's also based on an unforgettable personal experience. The story he told me has the ring of a Hollywood thriller, but with a catch. Doug, our leading man, is
一个断路器来削弱我们进行逻辑思考的能力呢？道格·菲尔兹长期以来一直对这个问题感到困惑。他对愤怒的兴趣源于他对大脑的着迷，但这也基于一段难忘的个人经历。他告诉我的这个故事听起来像是一部好莱坞惊悚片，但其中有一个转折。道格，我们的男主角，
not a muscle-bound hero. He's a neuroscientist. And not just any neuroscientist, but a walking stereotype of a neuroscientist. Here's his daughter, Kelly Fields. We'd be watching a movie together and there's some sort of car accident or some, you know, big scene going on and he'll just sort of chime in and be like, wow, there, you know, you can't see the shadow behind that plant in the corner anymore. Like, did you notice that they changed the lighting for no reason, even though it's the same scene? And I would be like, no, actually I was watching the car accident. So yeah,
不是一个肌肉发达的英雄。他是一位神经科学家。而且不仅仅是一位普通的神经科学家，更是一个行走的神经科学家刻板印象。这是他的女儿，凯利·菲尔兹。我们一起看电影时，如果碰巧发生某种车祸或什么宏大的场景，他就会突然插话说：哇，在那里，你看不到角落里那株植物后面的阴影了。就像，你有没有注意到他们无缘无故地改变了灯光，尽管是同一个场景？我会说：不，其实我在看车祸。所以，
just a very sort of typical nerd. Doug is five foot seven and weighs maybe 135 pounds. Glasses, thin hair. Don't think of Sean Connery or, you know, Matt Damon. You got to think of Woody Allen here. In 2007, Doug was scheduled to go to Barcelona to present some research at a neuroscience conference. He decided to turn a work trip into a father-daughter vacation and took Kelly with him.
就是一个非常典型的书呆子。道格身高五英尺七英寸，体重大概135磅。戴着眼镜，头发稀疏。不要把我想象成肖恩·康纳利或者马特·达蒙。在这里你得把我想象成伍迪·艾伦。2007年，道格计划去巴塞罗那在一个神经科学会议上发表一些研究成果。他决定把一次工作旅行变成一次父女度假，并带上了凯利。
She was 17. He was 57. Their first stop was Paris. Waiting in line at the Eiffel Tower, Kelly got a new glimpse into how her dad's mind worked. A couple came up to us and was speaking perfect English with American accents and they were very nice and I just noticed they were standing too close to us. I kept glancing behind us, sort of like, why are you standing so close?
她当时17岁。他57岁。他们的第一站是巴黎。在埃菲尔铁塔排队时，凯利对她父亲大脑的运作方式有了新的认识。一对夫妇走近我们，说着带美国口音的流利英语，他们非常友好，我只是注意到他们离我们太近了。我不断回头看，心想：你们为什么站得这么近？
And I noticed this woman's hand near his pants. And then I look again and I notice his pocket is unzipped. And I just sort of whispered to my dad, I think they're trying to rob you. Doug was completely unfazed. My dad informed me that that was a decoy wallet. Your dad had a decoy wallet? You are just as surprised as I was.
我注意到这个女人的手靠近他的裤子。然后我再看一眼，发现他的拉链没拉上。我就低声对爸爸说：我觉得他们想偷你的钱包。道格完全无动于衷。我爸爸通知我那是诱饵钱包。你爸有个诱饵钱包？你和我一样惊讶。
I was like, what? He had this special wallet that he would keep in his front pocket. It was special because the way it was cut to fit into his front pocket. And that was his wallet. Sorry, I'm blowing all your covers, dad. And then he had a fake wallet in his back pocket
我当时想：什么？他有一个特殊的钱包，放在前裤兜里。这个钱包很特殊，因为它的剪裁正好适合放进他的前裤兜。那才是他的钱包。对不起，爸爸，我把你所有的秘密都泄露了。然后他在后裤兜里放了一个假钱包，
with not a lot of money in it and a few fake credit cards. Duck came up with a strategy many vacations ago. You know, when you travel, it's a wise idea not to have all your money and credit cards in one place. You know, you can get robbed or mugged. And so the idea is, you know, if it's a pickpocket and they get a wallet that's useless, that doesn't matter. But if you're mugged, you can hand them the wallet or throw it on the ground and run.
里面没有多少钱，还有几张假信用卡。道格在好几次度假前就想出了这个策略。你知道的，当你旅行时，把所有的钱和信用卡放在一个地方是不明智的。你知道的，你可能会被抢劫或持械抢劫。所以这个想法是，如果是扒手，他们拿到了一个毫无用处的钱包，那没关系。但如果你被抢劫了，你可以把钱包递给他们或者扔在地上然后逃跑。
So that's why I do that. For anyone keeping score, that's neuroscientist one, pickpockets, zero. After visiting the Eiffel Tower, father and daughter went back to their hotel and packed their bags. The next day, they took the metro to the airport. This is when Doug broke one of his cardinal rules. I violated my rule of having money in multiple places because TSA makes that difficult when you have to go through inspections. So I figured we're just going to take the ride to the airport.
这就是我这么做的原因。对于任何记分的人来说，那是神经科学家1比扒手0。参观完埃菲尔铁塔后，父女俩回到酒店收拾行李。第二天，他们坐地铁去机场。正是在这个时候，道格打破了自己的一条铁律。我打破了将钱放在多个地方的规定，因为当你必须通过安检时，TSA会让这变得困难。所以我想我们只要坐车去机场就行了。
So I had everything in my wallet. Everything in one wallet. We got on the metro, lots of people. Then we came to a stop and everybody on the metro train left. Except one lady who looked very sympathetic at us and I felt that my wallet was gone. They had lost their money and credit cards. That's neuroscientist Juan, pickpockets Juan.
所以我把所有的钱都放在钱包里。所有的东西都在一个钱包里。我们上了地铁，人很多。然后我们停了下来，地铁上的所有人都下车了。除了一个看起来对我们非常同情的女士，我觉得我的钱包不见了。他们的钱和信用卡丢了。那是神经科学家1比扒手1。
Doug and Kelly still had their passports, so they were able to get on their flight to Barcelona where Doug's conference was being held. If you have your wallet stolen in Europe, how do you check into a hotel? What are you going to do? What ultimately happened is I managed to reach my brother in the United States and he arranged to wire us cash. My brother had picked this place for us to get money, kind of at random on the internet. Doug and Kelly got in a cab and gave the driver the address of the bank where they were to pick up the money.
道格和凯利还保留着护照，所以他们得以登上飞往巴塞罗那的航班，道格的会议就在那里举行。如果在欧洲钱包被偷了，你怎么入住酒店？你要怎么办？最终发生的事情是，我想办法联系了我在美国的兄弟，他安排给我们电汇现金。我兄弟在网上随机挑选了这个地方让我们取钱。道格和凯利叫了一辆出租车，把银行地址告诉了司机，他们要去那里取钱。
Except, it wasn't a bank. So we got in a cab, took us way out of the Barcelona tourist area to the most seedy neighborhood you've ever seen. As vacant shops and trash-strewn streets replaced sprawling parks and cafes, father and daughter got more and more anxious. Our adrenaline is like coming out our ears already because we've just been pickpocketed
但是，那不是一家银行。所以我们上了出租车，它把我们带出了巴塞罗那的旅游区，来到了你见过的最藏污纳垢的街区。随着荒废的店铺和垃圾遍地的街道取代了广阔的公园和咖啡馆，父女俩越来越焦虑。我们的肾上腺素已经直冲脑门了，因为我们刚被偷了钱包，
and had all this stress. And we end up in a seedy part of town at an internet cafe. And it was just a small dingy building full of really big men, basically. The burly man was staring at a TV. When Doug and Kelly entered, the men silently turned to watch. Doug went up to the cashier. I gave him this receipt. He reaches in his pocket, pulls out this wad of money,
承受了这么大的压力。最后我们到了城里一个藏污纳垢地方的一家网吧。那只是一栋又小又破旧的建筑，里面基本上全是大块头男人。那个粗壮的男人正盯着一台电视。当道格和凯利走进去时，男人们默默地转过身来看着他们。道格走到收银员面前。我把这张收据交给他，他把手伸进口袋，掏出一叠钱，
and starts peeling off, you know, $1,000 or something. And we were just standing there sort of looking at them like, are you contacting your friends to come and rob us? Kelly and I just know we're going to get robbed again. It was terrible. They didn't get robbed. The cab stayed there. We got in the cab and then we went back. The next morning they resolved to put the unpleasantness of the previous days behind them. Doug had to give a talk at the conference that afternoon. In the morning he and Kelly decided to visit a famous Barcelona cathedral.
开始数出，你知道的，1000美元左右。我们当时就站在那里看着他们，心想：你们是在联系朋友来抢劫我们吗？我和凯利都知道我们又要被抢劫了。太可怕了。他们没有被抢劫。出租车一直停在那里。我们上了车，然后回去了。第二天早上，他们决定把过去几天的糟糕经历抛在脑后。道格那天下午要在会议上做演讲。早上他和凯利决定去参观巴塞罗那著名的座堂。
Now, it would seem like too much bad luck to get robbed again, but... We're coming up the steps of the metro station, and suddenly I felt this tug at my pant leg, and I slapped the zipper pocket above my knee and my wallet was gone. This wasn't a decoy wallet. It was the real thing, with all the cash that Doug's brother had wired him from the United States. Something snapped inside the 57-year-old neuroscientist. He was done being used as a portable ATM by European thieves.
现在，再被抢劫一次似乎显得运气太差了，但是……我们正走上地铁站的台阶，突然我感到膝盖上方的裤腿被拉了一下，我拍了拍膝盖上方的拉链口袋，钱包不见了。这不是一个诱饵钱包。那是真家伙，里面装着道格的兄弟从美国电汇给他的所有现金。这位57岁的神经科学家内心有什么东西断裂了。他受够了被欧洲小偷当成移动取款机。
I shot my arm back. The robber hadn't gotten far. He was right behind Doug. He started to turn, and I snagged him in the crook of my arm. He had the robber around the neck. Now what? Doug didn't have to ask himself the question.
我把手臂往后一甩。小偷没跑远。他就在道格身后。他开始转身，我用手臂弯把他给卡住了。他把小偷的脖子锁住了。现在怎么办？道格不需要问自己这个问题。
His arm seemed to know what to do. I flipped him over my hip to the ground on the pavement, jumped on his back and put him in a chokehold and then this thought bubbles up to my cerebral cortex. What are you doing? If you're Rob, you should give him the money. But I was sort of just like a spectator in this whole thing. Kelly, who was a couple of paces in front of Doug, turned around to see something she never expected to see in all her life.
他的手臂似乎知道该怎么做。我把他从我的臀部翻过摔倒在人行道上，扑到他背上，对他使出了锁喉，然后这个想法涌入我的大脑皮层。你在干什么？如果你被抢了，你应该把钱给他。但我当时就像这整件事的一个旁观者。走在道格前面几步的凯利转过身，看到了她一生中从未想过会看到的一幕。
Wild, red rage from her father. And I see my dad choking this random person. He has this young guy in a headlock. And I was just looking at him like, what is going on? And I hear my dad yell, my wallet! And when he says my wallet, I knew instantly what had happened. Somebody had pickpocketed him again. So I'm on the ground with this guy, and he's in his 20s. I'm just thinking back to watching my kids wrestle. And I'm trying to do what they do. I'm thinking hip control, I gotta keep this down, keep him pinned. And I yell, call the police, call the police, I've got
她父亲身上爆发出的狂野、血红的怒火。我看到我爸爸在掐一个陌生人。他把这个年轻小伙子锁喉了。我当时看着他，心想：这到底是怎么回事？我听到我爸爸大喊：我的钱包！当他说“我的钱包”时，我立刻明白了发生了什么。有人又偷了他的钱包。所以我跟这家伙一起倒在地上，他二十多岁。我脑子里回想起看孩子们摔跤的情景。我试图做他们做的事。我在想臀部控制，我得把这个人按住，把他压制住。我大喊：报警，报警，我抓住他
him. And there's no, no reply. And then from my perspective on the ground, all I saw were men's feet circling around me. And I then realized they were all part of a gang. The thief somehow managed to fling Doug's wallet toward an accomplice. It was now Kelly's turn to do something crazy. The next thing I see is a woman's hand flying through the air, and I recognize it as Kelly. Kelly was captain of the Ultimate Frisbee team at that time, and she's doing a full-on layout on a solid concrete to deflect the disc, you know, and taps the wallet into my outstretched right hand.
了。没有人回应。从我倒在泥里的视角来看，我只看到男人们的脚在我周围盘旋。然后我意识到他们都是一伙的。小偷设法将道格的钱包扔向了一个同伙。现在轮到凯利做出一件疯狂的事情了。接下来我看到的是一只女人的手在空中飞过，我认出那是凯利。凯利当时是极限飞盘队的队长，她在坚硬的水泥地上进行了一次全力以赴的扑救，试图挡住飞盘，你知道的，然后把钱包拍进我伸出的右手。
And I sort of jump up to my feet, and I'm looking around like, okay, now what? And I see these big guys and I watch, I follow the gaze of one of these guys, I follow his eyes as he looks down at the ground and I see that he sees my dad's blackberry. And as I'm locking eyes with him, I jumped on my dad's blackberry, just like a football player would like grab a football
我从地上跳起来，环顾四周，心想：好吧，现在怎么办？我看到这些大块头男人，我看着，我顺着其中一个家伙的目光看去，我顺着他的眼睛看着地面，我看到他看到了我父亲的黑莓手机。正当我与他四目相对时，我扑向了我爸爸的黑莓手机，就像美式足球运动员扑向橄榄球
or something, which is a funny image to me because it was just a blackberry. So I'm like on the ground hugging this little blackberry and I'm like, dad I got your phone! And I'm yelling because there's now a circle of men around me and I can see through their feet there's a circle of men around my father as well. And he has his wallet, and he knew the next move, and that was to let the guy go. That's Neuroscientist 2, Pickpockets 1. When I let the bandit go that I had in the chokehold,
或类似的东西，这在我看来是一个有趣的画面，因为那只是一部黑莓手机。所以我趴在地上抱着这个小小的黑莓手机，喊道：爸，我拿到你的手机了！我在大喊，因为现在我周围围着一圈男人，透过他们的脚，我能看到我父亲周围也围着一圈男人。他拿回了钱包，他知道下一步该怎么做，那就是放了那个家伙。那是神经科学家2比扒手1。当我放开那个被我锁喉的强盗时，
he scooted away on his back, kind of like on his butt, sort of like a crab, and he pointed at me going, crazy man, crazy man. And now I'm staring eye to eye with like the ringleader and all these other guys. So what am I gonna do now? I had so much adrenaline going, which I've never felt before. I was ready to throw him into his accomplices
他倒退着滑开，有点像坐在屁股上，像螃蟹一样挪动，他指着我说：疯子，疯子。现在我和首领以及其他所有人四目相对。那我现在该怎么办？我体内积聚了大量的肾上腺素，这是我从未感受过的。我准备把他扔向他的同伙，
and knock him down the steps into the Metro station. And there was no question whether I could do that or not. And then, yeah, really pretty well-dressed elderly man with a cane just sort of walks up really casually and said, yeah, he's no crazy, go. walks up really casually and said, yeah, he's no crazy, go. And they all fled, you know, like a bunch of birds leaving a telephone wire or something.
把他撞下台阶摔进地铁站。我能不能做到这一点根本不是个问题。然后，是的，一个穿着得体、拄着手杖的老年男子非常随意地走过来，说：是的，他不是个疯子，走吧。非常随意地走过来，说：是的，他不是个疯子，走吧。他们全都逃跑了，你知道的，就像一群鸟离开电话线一样。
They were just like, poof. And I'm just sort of like trying to process it all, like what just happened? Oh, my dad must be a spy. This is, of course. And he just like did some spy things when that guy stole his wallet. He's not really a scientist at all.
他们就像是：砰的一下消失了。我当时就像是在试图消化这一切，心想：刚刚发生了什么？哦，我爸爸一定是个间谍。当然是这样。当那个家伙偷了他的钱包时，他只是做了一些间谍的动作。他根本不是什么科学家。
Doug and Kelly stumbled away from the scene. Their hearts were racing. My dad says, you know, we have to get a knife. And I was like, what? OK, now I'm concerned. That's like a horrible idea on multiple levels. That's a really bad idea, you know And I couldn't believe that my father who I had only ever seen
道格和凯利跌跌撞撞地逃离了现场。他们的心狂跳不已。我爸爸说：你知道，我们得弄把刀。我当时想：什么？好吧，我现在开始担心了。从多个层面上讲，这都是一个可怕的主意。这真的是一个非常糟糕的主意，你知道的。我简直不敢相信，我那个我只见过
Use knives for like cutting vegetables or firewood Was now suggesting like we need to go get a weapon and I was sort of like, okay I need to step in and the decision-making process that's insane. We're not getting a knife Doug was sure that they were being tracked by members of the street gang. And it turns out he was not being paranoid. He and Kelly really were being followed. Now it turned into a scene out of it like a spy movie.
用刀切蔬菜或劈柴的父亲，现在竟然建议说我们需要去找一把武器，我当时就觉得：好吧，我需要介入，这个决策过程太疯狂了。我们不去找刀。道格确信他们正被街头帮派的成员追踪。事实证明，他并不是被迫害妄想症。他和凯利确实被跟踪了。现在情况变成了一场谍战电影里的场景。
We're running down back alleys. We're running through restaurants, going into shops, going in one door, out the back door. And so we go into a different shop and I bought this like skirt so we could try and change clothing which was really bizarre and it's funny that we thought that would help. And we get out of the store and I remember seeing another person walking towards us on one side of the street and then a group of men walking towards us on the other side and
我们在小巷里奔跑。我们穿过餐馆，进入商店，进了一个门，又从后门出去。所以我们走进另一家商店，我买了一条裙子，这样我们就可以试着换衣服了，这真的很诡异，而且我们当时居然觉得这会有用，这太搞笑了。我们走出商店，我记得看到另一个人在街的一侧向我们走来，然后一群男人在街的另一侧向我们走来，
my dad just goes we need to cross the street. Ready? Go. Like no conversation and we just started booking it across this crowded road and we run across the street. We realize these people are following us foreshore. We see them now crossing the crosswalk to come to our side of the street again and we're like, what do we do? And he goes, let's get a taxi and we run into the street and he like hits the hood of a taxi driving by, you know, and he's like, we need to get in. When they got out of the taxi, by you know and he's like we need to get in. When they got out of the taxi they still hadn't shaken the robbers. They jumped in another cab and asked the driver to get them the hell out of Barcelona. Ben went to the next city with 170 year old cab fare I still remember.
我爸爸直接说：我们需要过马路。准备好了吗？走。没有任何对话，我们开始全速穿过这条拥挤的马路，我们跑过街道。我们意识到这些人绝对在跟踪我们。我们现在看到他们穿过人行横道，再次来到我们这一侧的街道，我们心想：我们该怎么办？他说：我们叫辆出租车吧。他冲向马路，拍打着一辆开过去的()},格，你知道的，他说：我们需要上车。当他们从出租车里出来时，你知道的，他说：我们需要上车。当他们从出租车里出来时，他们依然没有摆脱劫匪。他们跳上另一辆出租车，要求司机带他们滚出巴塞罗那。我们去了下一个城市，我还记得170年的出租车费。
of the Euro cab fare I still remember. It was here, far outside of Barcelona, that Doug's heart rate started to slow. And as his normal, logical brain came back online, he couldn't believe what he had just done. He's like, I should have given them my wallet. That's crazy, why did I do that? Why was I doing that? Like never do that. If this ever happens to you again, you know have given them my wallet. That's crazy. Why did I do that? Why was I doing that?
我还记得那欧元的出租车费。正是在这里，在巴塞罗那郊外很远的地方，道格的心率开始减慢。当他正常、理智的大脑恢复运转时，他简直不敢相信自己刚才做了什么。他说：我本该把钱包给他们的。太疯狂了，我为什么要这么做？我当时在干什么？千万别那样。如果这种事再发生在你身上，你知道的……我本该把钱包给他们的。太疯狂了。我为什么要这么做？我当时在干什么？
Like, never do that. If this ever happens to you again, you know, give me your wallet. Doug's behavior disturbed him as a father, but it also disturbed him as a neuroscientist who thought he had a good handle on how the brain worked, on how his own brain worked. From a neuroscience perspective, how does this happen that you can instantly do this aggression without even being aware and it's all unconscious? If something in my environment could cause me to suddenly risk life and limb with no conscious thought, I wanted to understand how that worked at a neuroscience level, what's
就像，千万别那样。如果这种事再发生在你身上，你知道的，把钱包给他。道格的行为作为父亲让他感到不安，但作为一名自以为对大脑运作方式、对自己大脑运作方式了如指掌的神经科学家，这也同样让他感到不安。从神经科学的角度来看，你是怎么做到在甚至没有意识到的情况下瞬间做出这种攻击行为的，而且这一切都是无意识的？如果我环境中的某些东西会让我突然在没有意识思维的情况下拿生命去冒险，我想从神经科学的层面去理解那是如何运作的，大脑中究竟发生了什么。
going on in the brain. The question again was why evolution, which has sculpted our brains and bodies to be skilled survival machines, would preserve systems in the brain that cause us to act with unthinking haste and violence. Haste and violence that can place our own lives at great risk. Doug wrote a book as he pondered this question. It's called Why We Snap? Understanding the rage circuit in your brain. He realized that the answer lay in
问题依然是，为什么已经将我们的大脑和身体雕塑成熟练生存机器的进化，会保留那些导致我们做出不经思考的鲁莽和暴力行为的大脑系统？这种鲁莽和暴力会将我们自己的生命置于巨大的风险之中。道格在思考这个问题时写了一本书。书名叫《我们为什么会情绪失控？理解你大脑中的愤怒回路》。他意识到答案就在
the question itself. It was all about speed. The conscious brain is too slow and it doesn't have the capacity. So when you're faced with a sudden threat, like a fist thrown to your chin, you have to respond faster than the conscious brain can handle it. There are lots of things that can be done slowly, but surviving an immediate threat is not one of them. When you're dealing with a predator or some other imminent danger, you have to act fast.
问题本身之中。这一切都关乎速度。有意识的大脑太慢了，而且容量不够。因此，当您面临突发威胁时，例如下巴挨了一拳，您的反应速度必须快过有意识大脑的处理能力。有很多事情可以慢慢做，但应对眼前的威胁绝不是其中之一。当您面对掠夺者或其他迫在眉睫的危险时，您必须迅速行动。
So nature has developed high-speed pathways to the amygdala. All our senses go there before they go to the cortex, which is where we have consciousness. And that's so you can have this rapid response to a real threat. Now we've all experienced this. You're on a basketball court and wayward basketball comes towards you and you duck and turn and you bat it away, and then you go, what was that? Your unconscious mind detected because visual input went first to your amygdala that something was in your visual space that shouldn't be there. Sort of like a motion detector, but not only that, then put you on a very definitive course with a complex behavior. You think about the behavior where you turn and you intersect this thing
因此，大自然进化出了通往杏仁核的高速通路。我们所有的感官在到达大脑皮层（我们产生意识的地方）之前，都会先到达那里。这样你就能对真实的威胁做出这种快速反应。现在我们都经历过这种事。你在篮球场上，一个飞来的篮球朝你砸来，你躲闪、转身并把它拍开，然后你会想：刚才那是什么？你的无意识思维检测到，因为视觉输入首先到达了你的杏仁核，表明你的视觉空间里出现了不应该出现的东西。有点像运动探测器，不仅如此，它还会引导你进入一个具有复杂行为的明确轨道。想想那种行为，你转身并迎上这个东西
and you bat it away. Rational thought isn't just unhelpful when that basketball is hurtling toward you. It's actually counterproductive. Being deliberate can end up getting you smashed in the face. But short-circuiting logic creates dangers, especially when you're in the grip of an emotion like rage. You can literally stop thinking about your arm as your arm. It becomes a weapon that can be wielded, deployed, sacrificed.
把它拍开。当那个篮球朝你呼啸飞来时，理性思考不仅毫无用处，实际上还会适得其反。三思而后行最终可能会导致你的脸被打碎。但短路逻辑会带来危险，尤其是当你陷入像愤怒这样的情绪时。你甚至可以不再把自己的手臂当作手臂。它变成了一种可以挥舞、部署、牺牲的武器。
The brain's threat detection mechanism, which is highly controlled, to engage in a violent, aggressive interaction risks life and limb. Most of the time, we are well served by being logical and deliberate. But on rare occasions, it's helpful to act with unthinking haste.
大脑高度受控的威胁检测机制，参与暴力、攻击性的互动会冒着生命危险。大多数时候，保持理智和深思熟虑对我们很有帮助。但在极少数情况下，不经思考地草率行事也是有帮助的。
The operative word here is rare. What Doug has found is that wild red rage erupts in very specific situations, often when you're defending your most vital interests. The brain controls this response so that it's only tripped by very specific triggers. Doug says most of these triggers are related to our basic needs. For example, you can easily imagine an animal or a human reacting with protective rage when its own life is in danger. Life for limb. If you're attacked you will fight back. There's nothing to lose. All animals will do that.
这里的关键词是“罕见”。道格发现，狂野的血红怒火只在非常特定的情况下爆发，通常是在你捍卫最生死攸关的利益时。大脑控制这种反应，使其只被非常特定的触发因素激活。道格说，这些触发因素大多与我们的基本需求有关。例如，你可以很容易地想象，当动物或人类自身的生命处于危险之中时，会以保护性的愤怒做出反应。生命攸关。如果你遭到攻击，你就会反击。没有什么可失去的。所有动物都会这么做。
Another thing most animals will do? Protect their young. You know the rule. Never get between a mama bear and her cub. And while you're at it, don't try to steal her dinner. Resources. That was the other thing that was tripped when my wallet got snagged.
大多数动物还会做另一件事？保护它们的幼崽。你知道那个规则。永远不要夹在母熊和她的幼崽之间。顺便说一句，不要试图偷走她的晚餐。资源。当我的钱包被抢时，被触发的就是这个。
Even a family puppy will snap at your hand if you get too close to the dish. The list goes on. Don't try to take my mate. Don't encroach on my territory. Don't corner me. If an animal is trapped, it will use aggression to break free.
如果你靠得太近，甚至连家里的宠物狗都会对你的手龇牙咧嘴。这样的例子不胜枚举。不要试图抢走我的伴侣。不要侵犯我的领地。不要把我逼入绝境。如果一只动物被困住了，它会用攻击性来打破束缚。
I mean, an animal trapped will chew its leg off. But so will a human. These triggers remind us of a truth we cannot avoid. Humans, at the end of the day, are animals. But we're also more complicated than this list may suggest. One story that made an impression on Doug involved a man named Ray Young. He was 67 years old and lived in Silver Spring, Maryland, where Doug lived too. Ray was waiting his turn at a post office one day when he saw what he thought was another customer cut the line.
我的意思是，被困住的动物会咬断自己的腿。人类也是如此。这些触发因素提醒我们一个无法回避的真相：归根结底，人类也是动物。但我们也比这份清单所暗示的要复杂得多。有一个给道格留下深刻印象的故事涉及一个名叫雷·扬的男子。他67岁，住在马里兰州银泉市，道格也住在那里。一天，雷在邮局排队等候时，看到他认为是另一个顾客插队了。
The next thing that happened was unbelievable. He pulled out a knife and started knifing the guy viciously. I went to many of his trials and, you know, he had no record of violence, no arrest record, is completely out of character. RAY RAY SNAPPED because he was defending something that is of vital importance to humans. Order in society, this guy broke the rules, he cut in line. We all depend on a functioning social order. A stable, rule-following society is as essential to our survival as food and shelter. We are willing to fight to maintain such order. In social animals, in order to maintain order following the rules, aggression is what is
接下来发生的事情令人难以置信。他掏出一把刀，开始凶狠地捅那个家伙。我旁听了他的很多庭审，你知道的，他没有暴力记录，没有被捕记录，这完全不符合他的性格。雷情绪失控了，因为他在捍卫对人类至关重要的事情。社会秩序，这家伙破坏了规则，他插队了。我们都依赖一个正常运转的社会秩序。一个稳定的、遵循规则的社会对我们的生存至关重要，就像食物和住所一样。为了维护这种秩序，我们愿意战斗。在社会性动物中，为了维护遵循规则的秩序，攻击性就是
used. That's still what we use. We use violence. Now, it's not as if every threat produces mindless rage. Plenty of people see the social order breached or get insulted and don't turn into Rambo. The threshold for snapping and the drivers of violence can vary between people. So sometimes the right thing to do is to be the Marine and charge after the threat and sometimes that's going to get you killed. But as a species, the group as a whole will survive because somebody's going to do one
所采用的手段。这仍然是我们使用的手段。我们使用暴力。现在，并不是说每一个威胁都会引发盲目的愤怒。很多人看到社会秩序被破坏或受到侮辱，并不会变成兰博。情绪失控的门槛和暴力的驱动因素在不同人之间可能会有所不同。所以有时候正确的做法是像海军陆战队一样冲向威胁，而有时候那会让你送命。但作为一个物种，群体作为一个整体将会生存下来，因为总会有人去做这件事。
thing and somebody's going to do something else. Doug says stress is often a factor in sending us over the edge. He sees stress at play in Jess Cavender's response to the armed robber. She didn't scream and dig her hands into the attacker when she first saw him. She tried to appease him. She had been enduring this for a while, and stress was building,
事情发生时，总有人会采取其他行动。道格表示，压力往往是让我们情绪失控的重要因素。他在杰丝·卡文德面对持枪歹徒时的反应中看到了压力的作用。她第一次看到袭击者时，没有尖叫，也没有扑上去和袭击者厮打，而是试图安抚对方。她已经忍受这种情况一段时间了，压力在不断积聚，
and it tripped that trigger. The resource trigger. She said that it was the most valuable thing in her life that she depended on for food and everything was her camera. And they weren't going to get it. Now there is a wrong lesson you can draw from this account of rage. You could say, look, Jess lost it. And because she became enraged, she managed to save her camera.
最终触及了那个开关。资源开关。她曾说，相机是她生命中最宝贵的东西，是她赖以谋生和维持一切的依靠。他们休想拿走。现在，你可以从这起愤怒事件中得出一种错误的教训。你可以说，看，杰丝当时情绪失控了。正因为她变得暴怒，她才设法保住了自己的相机。
Doug was furious at being robbed and his rage allowed him to take his wallet back from the Barcelona thieves. These examples suggest rage always results in good outcomes, that you would end up better off when you violently lose your temper. What this misses is that literally no one in their right mind will tell you to attack a man with a gun or to take on a street gang in a foreign country. Risking your life to save some money or to protect a camera is a very definition of foolishness. When we come back, why you can't understand the deep logic of blinding rage by looking only at situations where things turn out well for you.
道格对遭遇抢劫感到无比愤怒，他的怒火让他得以从巴塞罗那的小偷手中夺回钱包。这些例子似乎表明，愤怒总是能带来好结果，当你情绪失控诉诸暴力时，最终反而能过得更好。但这里忽视的一点是，理智健全的人绝对不会建议你攻击一个持枪歹徒，或者在异国他乡去挑衅一个街头帮派。为了省点钱或保护相机而冒着生命危险，这简直就是愚蠢的定义。稍后回来，我们将探讨为什么不能仅通过那些结果良好的情境，来理解盲目怒火背后的深层逻辑。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Mohammed Boazizi was sick of the police and their demands for bribes. He was a produce seller in the city of Sidi Bouzid in Tunisia, in North Africa. The harassment felt endless. On a Friday morning in December 2010, Mohamed had an encounter with the police. Years later, there are still varying accounts of what happened. According to some, a cop confiscated the scales
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。穆罕默德·布阿齐济对警察及其索贿的行为感到厌烦。他是北非突尼斯西迪布济德市的一名果蔬小贩。这种骚扰感觉永无止境。在2010年12月的一个周五早晨，穆罕默德与警察发生了冲突。多年后，关于当时发生的事情仍有各种不同的说法。根据一些人的说法，一名警察没收了秤，
that Mohammed used to sell his produce. Others said an officer wouldn't let him set up his stand. Some accounts said Mohammed was slapped or perhaps kicked. The street vendor did what citizens are supposed to do. He went to the authorities to protest his mistreatment. But when he got to the government building to lodge a complaint, he was barred from entry. Muhammad was gripped by an intense feeling of injustice. And then, he snapped. He doused himself with gasoline. Standing in front of the
那是穆罕默德用来卖菜的工具。另一些人则说，警察不允许他摆摊。还有说法称穆罕默德挨了耳光，甚至可能被踢了一脚。这名街头小贩做了公民应该做的事。他去找当局抗议自己受到的不公对待。但当他到达政府大楼准备申诉时，却被拒绝入内。穆罕默德被一种强烈的不公感所攫取。紧接着，他崩溃了。他把汽油浇在自己身上。站在那个对他关闭大门的政府大楼前，
government building that had shut the door on him, he struck a match and set himself ablaze. One of the last things onlookers heard from him were these words, How do you expect me to make a living? By the time the fire was doused and Muhammad was rushed to a hospital, Burns covered 90% of his body. He died a few weeks later. His story shows the self-destructive power of wild red rage. But it also reveals the hidden logic of fury.
他划了一根火柴，点燃了自己。旁观者从他那里听到的最后几句话之一是：“你们怎么能指望我谋生？”当大火被扑灭、穆罕默德被紧急送往医院时，烧伤面积已经达到了他身体的90%。几周后他去世了。他的故事展示了狂怒具有自我毁灭的力量。但也揭示了愤怒背后的隐藏逻辑。
Thousands of Muhammad's fellow Tunisians showed up at his funeral. On social media, he was dubbed a martyr. Members of the crowd shouted, farewell Muhammad, we will avenge you. We weep for you today. We will make those who caused your death weep. Ten days after Muhammad's death, with escalating protests around the country, the president of Tunisia ended a 23-year autocratic reign and fled the country. Within weeks, protests in Tunisia spread to other Arab countries in what came to be known as the Arab Spring. It is the end of an era in Tunisia.
成千上万的突尼斯同胞出现在他的葬礼上。在社交媒体上，他被尊为烈士。人群中有人高呼：“再见，穆罕默德，我们会为你复仇的。我们今天为你哭泣。我们要让那些造成你死亡的人哭泣。”穆罕默德死后十天，随着全国各地抗议活动的不断升级，突尼斯总统结束了长达23年的独裁统治并逃离了国家。几周内，突尼斯的抗议活动蔓延至其他阿拉伯国家，这就是后来被称为的“阿拉伯之春”。这是突尼斯一个时代的结束。
President Hosni Mubarak has stepped down. Neuroscientist Doug Fields has found that we are capable of fury when we want to defend our lives or protect family or guard resources. Rage can be triggered when we want to maintain the social order. It also serves another useful purpose. Rage acts as a signaling device. If you look at the long history of social protest, it's just clear that powerful emotions like anger and rage have a huge and have had a huge role to play
总统胡斯尼·穆巴拉克已经下台。神经科学家道格·费尔兹发现，当我们想要捍卫生命、保护家人或守护资源时，我们是有能力展现出狂怒的。当我们想要维护社会秩序时，愤怒也会被触发。它还服务于另一个有用的目的。愤怒可以作为一种信号装置。如果你回顾社会抗议的漫长历史，就会发现一个显而易见的事实：诸如愤怒和狂怒之类的强烈情感，在动员人们、激励人们以及将他们凝聚在一起推动正义的过程中，发挥了并将继续发挥巨大的作用。
in galvanizing people, motivating them, bringing them together in movements towards increased justice. This is Amiya Srinivasan, a philosopher at the University of Oxford. Amiya recognizes that rage does have costs, but she wants us to remember that it can be useful to communities, causes, and individuals. Anger can play this clarifying role for myself, so it can help me understand what's going
这是牛津大学的哲学家阿米娅·斯里尼瓦森。阿米娅承认愤怒确实有代价，但她希望我们记住，它对社区、事业和个人都可能是有益的。愤怒可以为我自身起到这种澄清的作用，所以它能帮助我理解正在发生的事情，对吧？它能让我对一些原本未曾意识到的道德和政治问题有所领悟。我开始意识到，其实其中正存在着某种不公。愤怒的好处并不止于它给个体带来的清晰认知。感到愤怒可以充当对其他人的某种警告信号。事实上，有很多社会心理学证据表明，感到愤怒可以成为改变他人行为的有效手段，
on, right? It can make me come to certain kinds of moral and political realizations I didn't have before. I come to realize there's actually an injustice at work. The benefits of anger don't stop with the clarity it brings to us as individuals. Getting angry can act as a certain kind of warning signal to other people. And in fact, there's a lot of social psychological evidence that suggests that getting angry can be an effective means of changing other people's
与那种认为只有通过冷静的群体审议才能让人改变的传统自由主义理解相反，实际上，愤怒有时是一种动员他人的有效社会信号。事实上，阿米娅辩称，当我们讨论狂怒时，区分短期内可能对个人产生反效果甚至有害的行为，以及这种狂怒对运动、群体和事业的实用性，是非常重要的。个体的愤怒往往会蔓延开来，变成群体的愤怒和集体的愤怒。而集体愤怒具有非凡的形式。
behavior, counter to the kind of standard liberal understanding where calm group deliberation is the only way to get people to change, actually getting angry sometimes is an effective social signal to motivate other people. In fact, Amiya argues, it's important when we talk about fury to distinguish between what might be counterproductive or even harmful to individuals in the short run and the usefulness of that fury to movements, groups, and causes. Individual anger can often spread and become communal anger and collective anger. And collective anger has extraordinary forms.
她让我思考一个社交情境中的例子。想象这样一个场景。你正在谈恋爱，而你的伴侣背叛了你。对出轨的情人感到愤怒，可能只会促使那个出轨的情人变本加厉。如果你的伴侣对你说：“你真不该生我的气，因为这只会让我更想出轨。”我的意思是，这是一个激怒人的回应。之所以让人火冒三丈，是因为它把你的愤怒仅仅当作一种工具，一种鼓励或阻止他或她行为的工具。
She asked me to think of an example in an interpersonal setting. Imagine the scenario. You're in a romantic relationship and your partner cheats on you. I mean it might be that getting angry at your cheating lover just encourages that cheating lover to cheat more. And if your lover were to say to you, well, you shouldn't get angry at me because it just makes me cheat more. And if your lover were to say to you, well, you shouldn't get angry at me because it just makes me cheat more. I mean, that's an infuriating response. And it's infuriating because it treats your anger as just an instrument, an instrument for encouraging
而事实上，愤怒与其他道德情感一样，是对世界的一种表态。一个愤怒的配偶所做的，不仅仅是表达对不忠的厌恶。她同时也在传递一个信号：即我们认为在社会及人际关系中，什么样的行为才是恰当的。她的愤怒向其他配偶传达了一个信息。
or discouraging his or her behavior. Whereas in fact, anger, like other moral emotions, is something that makes a claim about the world. An angry spouse does more than show her displeasure at infidelity. She's also sending a signal about the kind of behavior we think is appropriate in a society in interpersonal relationships. Her anger sends a message to other spouses.
她的愤怒向其他配偶传达了一个信息。显然，这并不是在有意识的层面发生的事情。狂怒会促使你为某事表明立场，并让你承担个人成本。通过短路理性，它让你忽视了这些代价。你的行为可能对你自己有害，但它可能对你所属的群体有益。这就是自然选择可能会保留这种行为的原因。我们拥有这些神经回路是因为我们需要它们，我们有暴力是因为不幸的是我们需要它们。当结果好的时候，我们不叫它崩溃。那时我们称之为英雄主义或机智果断。
Her anger sends a message to other spouses. Obviously, this is not happening at a conscious level. Rage can prompt you to take a stand about something and make you incur personal costs. By short-circuiting reason, it makes you ignore those costs. Your actions might be personally harmful, but it can help the group to which you belong. This is why natural selection might conserve such behavior. We have these circuits because we need them, we have violence because unfortunately we need them. We don't call it snapping when the outcome is good. Then we call it heroism or quick thinking.
事实上，狂怒可能是大自然让我们优先考虑群体利益而非狭隘的自身利益的一种方式。通过削弱逻辑和损害理性，我们可以被驱使去做一些如果我们只考虑自己时绝对不会做的事。所以，当有人违反了社会规范时，我们就会生气。同样，愤怒是在让你为战斗做准备。正如我们所知，有时这些情况会演变成悲剧。人们在路上发生争执并掏出了枪。为群体的利益行事并不总是正确或美德的事情。
Rage, in fact, might be one way that nature gets us to prioritize the interests of our groups over our narrow self-interest. By disabling logic and impairing reason, we can be prompted to do things that we would never do if we were only looking out for ourselves. So somebody violates a social norm and we become angry. And again, anger is preparing you to fight. And as we know, sometimes these turn out tragically. People get into a fight on the road and pull out a gun. Acting in the interest of a group is not always the right or virtuous thing.
恐怖组织长期以来一直利用狂怒作为招募新追随者的工具。党派政治的愤怒可能会让我们更多地去考虑狭隘群体的福祉，比如我们的政党，而不是更大群体的福祉，比如我们的国家。狂怒会导致大屠杀、战争和种族灭绝。这一切让我们陷入了两难境地。如果我们消除愤怒，或者从逻辑上决定何时该生气，我们就会失去突发愤怒的速度和力量。但是，如果我们任由怒火肆虐而不加抑制，
Terrorist organizations have long used rage as a recruiting tool for new followers. The anger of partisan politics can cause us to think more about the well-being of narrow groups, like our political parties, rather than the well-being of larger groups, like our nation. Fury can drive massacres, wars and genocide. All this leaves us in a bind. If we were to eliminate rage or to logically determine when to get angry, we lose the speed and potency of sudden anger. But when we allow our furies to flare unchecked,
我们可能会对自身和他人造成无谓的伤害。几个世纪前，哲学家亚里士多德曾说过：任何人都可以生气——这很简单；但要以正确的人、在正确的程度、在正确的时间、出于正确的目的、用正确的方式生气——这就没那么容易了。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括
we can cause senseless damage to ourselves and others. Many centuries ago, the philosopher Aristotle said, anyone can become angry. That is easy. But to be angry with the right person, to the right degree, at the right time, for the right purpose, and in the right way, that is not easy. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes
安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。今日节目的音频混音由Final Final V2的罗布·拜尔斯、约翰·埃文斯和迈克尔·雷菲尔德完成。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。今天的节目是我们“情感2.0”系列的最后一期。在过去的几周里，我们探讨了群体动力学如何塑造我们对生活和周围世界的感受。我们探讨了矛盾心理的重要性以及骄傲这种复杂的情感。如果您错过了该系列的任何一集，请务必返回我们的
Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Audio mix on today's episode by Rob Byers, John Evans Evans and Michael Rayfield of Final Final V2. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. I'm Hiddenbrain's executive editor. Today's show is the final episode in our Emotions 2.0 series. Over the past few weeks, we've talked about how group dynamics shaped the way we feel about our lives and the world around us. We've looked at the importance of ambivalence and the complex emotion of pride. If you missed any of the episodes in the series, be sure to go back and check them out on our
播客或访问我们的网站 hiddenbrain.org 收听。如果您在听完后还想了解更多关于《隐藏的大脑》的内容，请订阅我们的简报。在每一期中，我们都会为您带来关于人类行为的有趣观点和研究，以及一个脑筋急转弯和一个快乐时刻。您可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 订阅。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
podcast or on our website, hiddenbrain.org. If you want even more Hidden Brain after you're done with that, please subscribe to our newsletter. In each issue, we bring you interesting ideas and research on human behavior along with a brain teaser and a moment of joy. You can subscribe at news.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。